vanessa bouchard avocat spécialiste en
droit de la propriété intellectuelle
bonsoir vanessa bouchara merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france on
voit que c'est compliqué avec cette loi
elle repart en discussion et ne fait
toujours pas l'unanimité très critiquée
d'ailleurs de la part de la commission
des lois pourquoi est-ce un si grand
bras de fer à votre avis alors ce qui
est compliqué c'est qu'on met à la
charge des plateformes une un délai
extrêmement court pour bloquer un
certain nombre de contenus selon des
critères qui sont parfois peu défini et
ça peut ça peut créer une sorte de
d'incertitude et l'incertitude n'est
jamais n'est jamais n'est jamais
sécurisante pour les différents acteurs
du marché
alors de quel incertitudes vous parler
précisément justement en réalité qu'est
ce qu'on appelle qu'est ce qu'on appelle
contenu qui qui est susceptible d'être
considérée comme et ne sait tout ce qui
est contenu susceptible de porter
atteinte à la dignité humaine donc on a
un grand nombre de 2,2 de choses qui
rentrent dans cette acception et dans
ces conditions ça veut dire que de
manière très large les plateformes
auront une obligation de bloquer des
contenus qui seront susceptibles d'une
manière ou d'une autre de porter
atteinte à la dignité humaine qui est
essentiel et qui est un qui est quelque
chose de fondamental
et justement c'est cette notion un très
critiquée les députés ont rétabli un
justement les réseaux sociaux ce sont à
eux de retirer en moins de 24 heures les
contenus manifestement haineux ça veut
dire qu'on fait peser cette
responsabilité sur des réseaux sociaux
qui vont devenir ainsi les chercheurs
que les réseaux sociaux c'est aussi
notamment les gaffes a donc vous avez
par exemple google qui est astreint à
ses règles mais alors vous aurez sociale
active et youtube donc en fait on s'est
quand même assez large et effectivement
on fait peser sur eux une responsabilité
très importante avec des sanctions un
corollaire de sanctions très important
aussi et ce qui est principalement des
criées c'est qu'en réalité on se dit et
quel est le rôle du juge et quel est le
rôle qu'on veut donner assez assez plate
forme et est ce qu'il y aura un
arbitrage à un moment donné si les
plateformes faisais n'importe quoi est
ce que ce dernier sega favori voilà au
sens large ces réseaux sociaux sont ils
prêts justement à exercer ce rôle est un
censeur comment peuvent-ils finalement
se préparer à cela la question est
intéressant parce que chacun de ces deux
c'est chacune de ces plateformes a déjà
des règles internes donc en fait vous
avez déjà par souvent de l'intelligence
artificielle des mots qui sont bloqués
on ne peut pas forcément de utiliser
tous les maux sur l'ensemble de ses
plateformes mais ça leur met ça leur
rajoute à leurs règles internes des
règles qui finalement résulte de la
législation et qui s'imposeront à eux
avec des sanctions extrêmement forte si
elles ne sont pas respectées et la
question aussi qui se pose c'est est-ce
que ces plateformes seront en mesure de
faire intervenir des humains sur la la
la la la
le retrait de contenu on un délai aussi
bref à savoir en 24 heures c'est pas
certains peut-être qu'effectivement il y
aura que l'intelligence artificielle est
peut-être finalement d d d d d
appréhension des visions qui seront pas
forcément les bonnes alors les
détracteurs du texte estiment qui a
également un grand risque pour la
liberté d'expression qu'elle est vraie
on a parlé beaucoup de censure donc est
ce que tout le monde pourra dire
n'importe quoi
moi je trouve qu un exemple assez
intéressant c'est l'exemple du slip
français donc tout le monde a entendu
parler ces dernières semaines avec des
salariés
ont mis sur des réseaux sociaux ddd
contenus qu'ils ont été convaincus
qu'ils sont considérés de manière dans
l'opinion publique comme des contenus
racistes
la question qui se pose c'est est-ce qu
effectivement les là les plateformes
devront elles retireront cells aurait
certainement sous l'égide de la loi
retiré ce contenu mais ce qu'elle aurait
aussi retirer l'ensemble des
commentaires qui se sont qui se sont
posés en réaction à ce contenu
peut-être il y aurait peut-être
finalement eu un débat très limité sur
le sujet alors le texte prévoit
également la création d'un parquet
spécialisé dans la lutte contre les
propos haineux qui sera désigné par le
ministère de la justice après l'entrée
en vigueur de la loi
pourquoi la création d'un tel parc et
intervient maintenant et est ce que on
peut être tranquille en termes
d'indépendance alors le texte prévoit
d'abord la nomination d'un observatoire
qui va faire un certain nombre de
préconisations et effectivement disposer
d'un parquet spécialisé comme on a un
parc et anti criminalité
c'est quelque chose qui peut avoir du
sens dans un contexte particulier avec
dédé enfin internet qui va très vite
d finalement des atteintes qu'ils
prennent tout de suite une qui se
démultiplie à une vitesse pas possible
et effectivement avoir un avoir un des
organes judiciaires qu'ils puissent
qu'ils puissent qu'ils puissent avoir
une connaissance importante des des
outils et des règles de fonctionnement
peut éventuellement être utile alors on
se rend compte évidemment quand on vous
écoute parler
et voilà on a eu beaucoup d'invités qui
critiquaient cette loi que lutter contre
la cyber haine c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement compliqué elle que dans le
fond on est impuissant à ce qu'il ya de
vraies solutions aujourd'hui
en fait on est ce qu'on est impuissant
encore une fois tout va très vite on
on utilise j'ai l'impression l'ensemble
des acteurs du marché pour aider à
lutter parce que via les circuits
traditionnels ça prend du temps et
mettre à contribution ses plateformes ça
peut être utile après les plateformes
sont pas nécessairement ravi d'être mis
à contribution et d'avoir une loi qui
leur imposant un délai très bref contre
des sanctions extrêmement importante de
devoir retirer ses contenus
merci vanessa bouchard un avocat
spécialiste en droit de la propriété
intellectuelle d'avoir été avec nous en
direct les errances